foreign
forcing the audience to relive this
trauma again you want to bring back my
favorite post-apocalypse gay couple as
well please don't when I cried after
episode three my wife said I sounded
like a raccoon with four broken legs we
made him soup if Pedro Pascal shows up
at my house with or without a gun I'm
making him soup hell I'll make him a
souffle I like candles I'll put on some
music and then oh I'm sorry it's
actually not in the TV since script
that's my fan fiction sorry about that
you look anything like you a bit and I
ain't seen him come on Joel you kind of
walked into that one you might be armed
with a gun but Graham Green's armed with
wit and you will lose to it every time
have you seen The Green Mile he's
fantastic you've got a map why are you
lost must have missed all the street
signs in the enormous Forest
oh I don't know how many since I've
taken off for Bella Ramsay but it'll
never be enough go ahead and remove
another person I didn't mean to upset
you about your brother apologizing to
the man who just a second ago had a gun
pointed at you if your brother's west of
the river he's gone sure will disprove
this theory in about 20 minutes I'm okay
I'm okay are you you know what the best
thing to do during a panic attack is ask
the person suffering a bunch of Rapid
Fire questions that always calms me down
when I'm having a hole punch through my
chest by anxiety thinking you can
survive a Wyoming winter with just jeans
I'm not sure the writers have ever
visited Green River during the cold
season but you ain't walking around with
just denim for long each episode I'm
hoping we've seen the last of Joel and
Ellie continuously walking but each
episode proves that this will not be the
last of me being disappointed come down
from there you're gonna break your neck
dads can I have some though what just to
warm up alcohol warming up the body's a
myth and can actually lead quickly to
hypothermia especially under conditions
such as the ones Joel and Ellie are in
Joel is a terrible Father Figure and
somehow immune to hypothermia not sure
which I find more sinable I mean
probably the father thing but he should
still be suffering from hypothermia also
how does Joel even still have alcohol
when they were forced to only take a few
things did he really believe alcohol was
on that level of importance cheap I
would raise sheep they're quiet Joel has
obviously never been to a farm before
sheep are most certainly not quiet they
will bleed every night you want quiet
grow some crops plants are quiet
[Applause]
[Music]
actually her middle name is Kristen you
might want to reread some of those books
in the library Ellie Marlene she's a lot
of things but she's no fool if she says
they can do it they can do it maybe but
why is Joe believing this all of a
sudden he didn't want to keep
transporting Ellie until Tess made it
her dying wish for him to do just that
he flat out said he didn't believe there
was a possibility of a cure I know he
likes Ellie more but that changed his
entire opinion about the possibility of
a cure dream of sheep ranches on the
moon sheep ranches on the moon that's
almost as ridiculous as Whalers on the
moon who carry a harpoon and that is
quiet I checked my six I live for tracks
I found the high ground and I kept watch
you found The High Ground so you weren't
just taking lessons from din but from
Obi-Wan as well most impressive wake me
up before you go go random people on the
side of the bridge are random and they
appear to have cameras why do they call
it dressing it's like you could
undressing because it is it's like
undressing on the inside episode has
time for Ellie preparing her type five
damn you're nowhere Livingston so weird
that you named dropped the Revolutionary
War era New Jersey governor I don't see
what he has to do with this situation
see I didn't need to play the games to
get the show just needed my good
old-fashioned history degree that came
for the small price of forty thousand
dollars in student loans don't ask me I
don't have a clue you know you could
have just made something up great
suggestion I'm sure he'll keep that in
mind for later and it will cause no
trouble whatsoever look at that River
crazy blue actually I believe that
particular shade in the river is
Cerulean blue not crazy blue
matures how about we just talk this
through how about you shut the up
Wyoming units did you burn fact that he
will smell it and he will rip you up
then when the dog just get infected I
don't infectious disease much but I've
played Resident Evil enough to know I
don't want any zombie dogs roaming the
country now her
the dog wasn't growling at Joel upon
approach but is growling at Ellie even
though it smells nothing on her either
because I guess the dog has a great
sense of dramatic timing do you think
the ranger Joe here after 20 years of
living in a world of fungus infected
creatures would understand that the mask
going over the nose is probably the most
important part of wearing the mask
unless of course it's a political
statement in which I guess you can list
the cause of death later is Free Speech
just looking for my brother it's all
nothing more what's her name we're gonna
find out Tommy is at this settlement and
Maria is his partner still why did Maria
immediately think oh he's looking for
his brother I'm sure this is Tommy's
brother there aren't other people at the
settlement with missing family members
and honestly the idea that Joel would
have wandered into the territory of the
specific settlement that was housing
Tommy is wild enough in its own right
I'm handing out five sins of this whole
operation and if anyone has an issue
with that they can meet me at High Noon
by the sycamore trees I mean I won't be
there because I hate violence but the
sycamore trees are very pretty this time
of year how the did they have
enough spare horses for Joel and Ellie
to each get their own did the group have
two extra they brought along for the
hell of it or did these horses not bear
their former Masters to Good Fortune
it's been a while since we've had a
proper meal hey don't you dare insult
Florence's soup like that you had a
proper meal like two days ago you draw
power from a damn got that working a
couple years ago after that sewage
Plumbing water heaters bites this place
actually works this place
actually works Collective
ownership
so uh communism
ah I didn't like that it is that
literally this is the commune we're
communist admitting to being communists
which honestly would be like only the
176th thing to be scared of in this
post-apocalyptic venue it's right below
attacked by clowns and a few notches
above attacked by dogs dressed as clowns
holy what is up with this random
hand and why is no one saying anything
about it I guess I could set a community
wasting any resources on a bar but what
strikes me more odd is that there's a
working bar in this town and no one
except Joel and Tommy are currently at
it unless we get vacant I mean what's
even left making getting bacon your last
priority go grab some supplies and be
out of your hair in the morning telling
someone you're stealing some of their
without asking first
character who lost their child thinks
they see their child in a crowd and it
turns out to be someone else cliche I
have no idea who these people on the 10
hottest boys list are so this sentence
for Hocus Pocus you want to celebrate a
cool movie about witches from the 90s
get a sticker for The Craft
tampons and pads after the Apocalypse
think the qz is using resources to
manufacture feminine hygiene products
and wage or not bet they're still making
Viagra though leaving a fire going in
your house unattended and yes I know
lots of people do this but it doesn't
make it any less dangerous or sinful I'm
gonna get my scissors
that's all just the ends I promise well
I'm sure these are all very kind
gestures forcing someone to accept your
generosity without consent is
problematic the new clothes are nice but
you didn't ask if she had sentimental
attachments to her previous outfit and
now you're pressuring her into a haircut
that she probably needs but might not be
comfortable with yet the only people who
can betray us are the ones we trust well
that's not even remotely true you don't
need to trust someone to get betrayed
you think Lando trusted Vader when they
struck their bargain in Cloud City it's
not even a little and yet he was
betrayed all the same forcing kids to
watch the goodbye girl or laying the
metaphors on too thick in your episode
make your choice I choose both I figured
I'd save you the trouble how does this
town have so many clothes and shoes to
fit Joel and Ellie so perfectly it's
like that scene from the second season
of Prison Break where Michael digs up
all the outfits laid out for him and the
other guys no one had a clue would be
escaping with him also any season after
the first season of prison break today I
thought that dog was gonna tear apart
because it smelled something on her and
all I did was stand there but what
exactly was y'all supposed to do if you
try to save Ellie from The Dog most
likely both of them would have been shot
and killed that was a no-win situation
and Joel might have plenty to beat
himself up over but this is not one of
those things what exactly did you hear I
have to leave her you have to take her
eavesdropping poor kids make your choice
I choose both Maria told me about Sarah
no don't say another word great idea
Joel I think we should all just take a
second to think about the things we've
said and skip I sure as hell ain't your
dad hey Siri
set a reminder for the end of episode 8
to send it just in case Joel calls Ellie
like his baby girl or something I've set
that reminder would you like to hear
your list of appointments for tomorrow
uh sure you have an appointment with
your therapist labeled recovering from
The Last of Us at 11 A.M yeah that
sounds about right can you say goodbye
or something no I came here to steal one
of these horses and go Force dramatic
timing is forced and honestly not all
that dramatic you deserve a choice I
still think you'd be better off with
Tommy let's go I'm glad to see them
reunited but doing it this fast kind of
sucks the energy out of their last
argument we should have waited an
episode that way we had a week to really
marinate in their upcoming separation
doing it here makes the fight in
subsequent reunion kind of feel cheap
riding a horse riding a horse riding a
horse River it's a contractor that's
pretty cool Chris Pine and most people
that watched it might disagree with you
Ellie if the fireflies were nice enough
to spray paint their image so you knew
where to find them they could have at
least spray painted an X over the image
when they hightailed it out of Dodge
there are definitely doctors here
pointing out the obvious of course I
like to call it pulling a Diana Troy
sitting clickers yeah no fireflies
either maybe in all that research they
turned into Pokemon
episode teases us with humans turning
into monkeys but never shows us humans
turning into monkeys damn it all to Hell
hold up the fireflies have a base in
Fort Smith Arkansas I am Memphis
and Oklahoma City but Fort Smith have
you been there I refuse to believe the
fireflies would invest resources for
operations there now theophil on the
other hand
every watch this fight five times and
nowhere in it did I see the Bandit get
enough momentum to stab Joel with his
Bat hell half the fight Joel was behind
the Raider so I'm calling on
this reveal if you want to stab Joel
show the stabbing don't open your eyes
episode will let us know Joel's fate
before fading to Black on yet another
cliffhanger
frostbite took his noodles should have
stolen two rabbits hardly any meat on
him all right all right Mickey's a mouse
Donald's a duck Pluto's a dog what's
goofy put your hands up no what why not
I don't want to
[Music]
Brothers don't shake hands Brothers
gotta hold on
[Music]